girl we gotta talk when we last saw
Danny she was surrounded by some pretty
unhappy looking Dothraki yeah I know I
know
et hit the red carpet for the game of
Thrones season 6 premiere Sunday where
Emilia Clarke teased what's to come
including as she hopes less nudity for
the women and more for the men are you
hoping that that's gonna spark a change
in these last couple seasons oh yeah
damn straight you know cauldros not
being around for a while so yes who's at
the top of that list for you I mean
there's so many choices so many
attractive men in Westeros well yes tell
me about it there's a lot there's a lot
to choose one now we know that Westeros
has been a challenging place for Danny's
love life know what's Hollywood like for
a millions of life oh honey I'm just
working that out know what lessons about
love have you learned since stepping
into the Hollywood spotlight on the show
um I mean it good kind of it happened at
the same time as me kind of before
enough in my 20s so there was a lot
there's a lot that I find out that I
that I've had an opportunity of learning
and let me match the safety of the show
e-series being incredible